yeah welcome to this blitz video zette
TFS from Switzerland I hope yeah okay so
um Kings Indian or young kings inion I
still have 5 2 transpose to the
Leningrad Dutch but not this time ok we
have a double fianchetto setup which now
looks a lot like in English opening yeah
let's try to use them pressure on the
long diagonal yeah this is actually am a
known theoretical line which I played
down myself for a bit of course I forgot
it I think it'd take care
yeah now I get get the default phone I'm
not sure I think yeah this is one idea
but I always thought that this sum
should be on rather than blacks favor
because the bishop is not a great great
piece and those parts are all on light
squares so it looks like him I might get
a favorable end game at one point of
course the thing everything works out
perfectly I mean it's not like there's a
great end game arising by force at just
the general idea who came this is
curious I don't think that you can
really keep the spawn and if not then it
looks really weak Queen a form hmm
no maybe maybe this is maybe he can play
that how do I really get this pawn look
B forms probably probably not the way to
go let's see if I can use the some snide
look before this is why I wanted to play
96 so that after rook before seat xb I
have 95 and now I have isolated this
pawn on e5 I hope this really falls now
otherwise it can get ugly I really need
to get the porn
I'm taking this first and i can i can
always take oops oops didn't see that
coming let's now i need to check this
now if i take b7 it takes before this is
ugly I shouldn't have allowed that yeah
this is very little now I mean I can I
can do that and probably I must him I
don't have any other move before hangs
and now unfortunately he gets rid of the
same hmm Kim this is unfortunately not
much not much on you can also say
nothing
yep just very drawers check check
okay let's let's draw this city cladding
the dryer really want to play this on
time yeah it's really a bit of a waste
of time I mean why not to just play in
the game um yeah I didn't really pay
attention to be should be some here I
think it's just a matter of some
accuracy and blackest is excellent I
just need to get the porn back and then
I have a great night on c5 he's got a
bad structure maybe it's not them it's
not them really working due to concrete
the concrete plane I need to take I just
I need just I can just take it I thought
them I can always do that but I didn't
didn't see a Bishop d7 I can just take
him and this is some quite nice you can
try that I now yeah just um just a
matter of how big blacks edges here in
the long run he needs to take them Sir
no no big choice then I get get to a to
something like this yeah if I have one
porn island and he's got this weakness
and this is not a good bishop it doesn't
do much can always also take it i've got
an excellent night here black is quite
substantially better it's not clear
vizinha for win but black is
much better I just thought that after
this move I didn't see Bishop e7 meant
my idea was I gained the tempo and then
I then I grab just a little bit more
convenient but Bishop e7 really is good
I cannot do that I thought because of
capturing I had as a six hanging ooh and
then oh where oh I didn't hit it I did
all of many things I can just take out
this is this is still something you can
try try to play as black it's it's it's
probably still a draw of course but it's
those are two weaknesses this is one
weakness so it's a little bit of
something yeah okay I'm a draw at the
end thanks for watching